the White House Press Secretary has
gotten a lot of things wrong in her
short tenure as the president's
spokesman and on Friday she continued
that Trend this time repeating a
falsehood about your favorite podcaster
I want to take a step back on
imma call out the shameful hateful and
dangerous attacks that we have been
seeing on the lgbtqi community as we've
seen this week as I said and also last
week look it started with the speaker at
a conservative conference calling for
the eradication of transgender people
language that not a single National
Republican leader has condemned now as
the liberal press was forced to admit
last week that is not what I said
and so some people right now are saying
that kjp is just really bad at her job
often she is
but this attack on me was not a mistake
it was I'm convinced a highly calculated
lie a desperate Hail Mary pass a last
ditch effort after a week-long failed
attempt by liberals to stop
conservatives from reframing the
transgender debate which the libs
thought they had already won we'll get
into it I'm Michael Knowles this Michael
Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment on Friday is from conservative
thinking moms some of my favorite kinds
of moms or those conservative thinking
ones who says this is trans History
Month women's history month has been
canceled that's that's true sorry guys
women's history month has transitioned
now the women's history month is to
honor men who to be women a lot of
craziness and instability
when times get crazy and unstable you
got to check out Birch gold right now
text Knowles to 98 98 98 in today's
economy it is more important than ever
to safeguard your financial future with
a diverse range of Investments the stock
market is unpredictable traditional
Investments bonds real estate they can
be affected by interest rates and other
economic factors that is why buying gold
with Birch gold is such a smart choice
gold is a tangible asset with a reliable
store of value because it is not tied to
any one economy or currency it can be a
safe haven in times of Crisis Birch gold
makes it easy to roll over your IRA or
401K into an IRA backed by physical gold
and silver right now if you buy gold you
can get a free safe to store it in that
is right unqualifying purchases now
through March 31st Birch gold will ship
a free safe directly to your door text
Knowles kwles to 98 9898 to claim your
free info kit on gold and to claim
eligibility for your free safe with your
retirement stake you want to be
confident in the financial services
companies that you work with including
who you choose for purchasing physical
precious metals text Knowles kwels to 98
98 98 and protect your savings with gold
today
I'm honored that the White House felt
the need to lie about me
and that is what this was
that that comment from Korean
Jean-Pierre was not a spontaneous
response to a reporter's question
that that comment from Kareem
Jean-Pierre was prepared I was in the
Press briefing and
I'll I can just tell you I've worked as
a campaign spokesman before I've done
that kind of job in politics obviously
not at the level that Karine Jean-Pierre
has but nothing in those briefings is
accidental every single word every
syllable is vetted and it was calculated
in in a couple really interesting ways
one she didn't say my name she didn't
say my name I think to allow her to
repeat the lie that I said that I called
to genocide transgender people or
whatever
she saw the whole White House saw that
the liberal media had to backtrack they
had to retract their claims of what I
said because they were afraid of libel
suits so she wouldn't say my name but
she did repeat that claim why repeat the
claim
because
the transgender debate is right at this
moment in the process of being reframed
which was the whole point of my speech
the whole point of my speech was that
the libs continue to win on these issues
and and that the trend is always the
libs propose something crazy
conservatives briefly oppose it the libs
stand firm conservatives then embrace
the views of our opponents so it
happened with feminism the crazy
feminists start burning their bras and
saying a woman needs a man like a fish
needs a bicycle the conservatives say
that's totally crazy then five seconds
later the conservatives say okay
feminism's fine but this sexual
Revolution stuff that's totally crazy
and then they accept that and they
accept the redefinition of marriage then
they accept transgenderism consider
where the transgender debate was even
two weeks ago the transgender debate was
the Liberals said we need to trans the
five-year-olds and the conservatives
said you need to wait till they turn
eight until you trans them but basically
everyone had accepted the premise the
transgenderism for adults was totally
fine if a 25 year old man wants to be
the opposite sex that's totally fine
that's his right he he should be allowed
to do that which is an insane position
obviously virtually no one in the
country left or right believed that even
10 years ago now because the Liberals
just constantly move that Overton window
to the left
they had effectively won that debate the
reason the lids reacted so strongly
against my speech was not anything
particularly special in the speech I
just said no we're I'm not conceding
that round transgenderism is either true
or false if it's true then it's true for
everybody of all ages if it's false as
it obviously is then it's false for
everybody of all ages and we shouldn't
tolerate it for anybody the second you
allow even one man one 50 year old man
that he's a woman in public life
you have granted the whole premise of
transgenderism women have lost their
bathrooms women have lost their sports
teams women have lost every special
right and privilege and space that they
have in public life and so it's it's an
all or nothing question there is no
middle ground so the White House had to
lie because
the attack from the media failed they
were forced to retract their libelist
statements
and then the attempt to cancel me failed
the conservative media rallied around me
and so this Hail Mary pass was from the
White House and
it makes sense when you realize that the
point was one to intimidate me into
recanting didn't work two to intimidate
the conservative movement the media into
canceling me didn't work and then three
this was the final volley
to intimidate Republican politicians
into disavowing me or conceding the
point
the reason I'm convinced this was so
highly calculated is
by getting the statement wrong the White
House was baiting Republican politicians
into calling them out and then once the
Republicans called them out the White
House could say all right well never
mind maybe we got the wording wrong but
where do you stand on this issue do you
want to eradicate transgenderism from
public life and the White House believed
that the Republican politicians were too
cowardly to do that and they didn't want
to open it up so they would be bullied
into silence and what the White House
wasn't counting on what the liberal
media were encounting on is that the
conservatives actually still have
something of a spine on this issue and
they were willing to take that there
Marsha Blackburn I mean there were so
many people in the conservative movement
who rallied here I certainly wouldn't
have time to thank everybody for doing
it and for having some courage and
standing up but everybody from the most
moderate part of the conservative
movement all of the way to the most
conservative the elected politicians the
media the activist groups Marcia though
I feel in particular was really precise
here she said
the White House and the press secretary
have become experts at spewing
misinformation and lies they want to
scare Americans into submission Michael
Knowles and that that was what this was
about
spew these lies
send a message to everybody that if you
in any way stand up against our
increasingly radical agenda we will try
to destroy you we will we will lie about
you it doesn't matter and
and conservative said no we don't care
we're not going to tolerate this
the the premise of this intimidation was
that conservatives don't want to be
viewed as going too far you know we just
want a moderate position we just want to
tack to the center here
if we go too far we're going to get
blown out at the ballots in in November
no that's not how the left thinks
that that piece of political common
sense is not very sensible actually
the left never worries about going too
far and alienating the Centrist voter
and sometimes it hits them a little bit
at The Ballot Box but in the long run it
doesn't they've won everything they've
gone for
they've redefined marriage they've
redefined man and woman
they're transiting the kids they don't
back down they push for the green New
Deal the green New Deal over 10 years
and 90 trillion dollar plan to
completely upend our whole political
order they're still pushing on that it's
becoming more and more mainstream every
day they pushed on to abolish the police
it hurt them a little bit in the
midterms
they still push and they have weakened
the police departments and they have
weakened law enforcement and they have
opened our border and they've succeeded
the the mistake that a lot of
conservatives have made in the past
they're not making it right now
fortunately is they think that political
movements are won by being the most
Centrist type of candidate you can
possibly be and following the the
consensus view that's not how political
movements are won political movements
are won by highly motivated groups of
political minorities who have a very
clear Vision who don't just follow the
consensus view but who craft the
consensus view that's how political
movements are one that's how the libs
have won for the last 50 70 years and if
conservatives want to start winning
we need that Clarity too
people want a choice not an echo to
quote Phyllis Schlafly one of the most
effective political activists of the
20th century people want leadership and
a Clear Vision they'll follow that
without a Clear Vision if we're just
going to be the Democrats light people
are going to vote for the Democrats
Democrats are much better at being
Democrats than we are the irony of all
of this by the way is that as the libs
are pretending that I called for mass
murder
a very prominent liberal went on
national television and literally called
for murder
we have experienced many decades now of
having agency over our body of being
able to determine when and how many
children to have we know what that feels
like we know what that's done for our
lives we're not going back I don't care
what the laws are we're not doing that
I think the women will rise up that's
the activists that's Jane speaking and
and she probably will get a Nobel Prize
it is the truth I'm not going to do it
marching and protesting what else do you
suggest
it's not a miraculous what did you say
Murder She
said she's just I don't say that you
don't know they'll pick up on that and
yeah she's just kidding it's well let me
talk to you about it
let's move on and talk about Jane's
activism which is legendary oh she's
just kidding she's just kidding you look
at Jane Fonda Jane Fonda is not kidding
at all there's not even the hint of a
theatrical kind of smile or Winker she
is dead serious which tells you a lot
about the left tells you two things in
particular one when they whine and cry
and clutch their pearls and completely
rewrite your words to make it sound as
though you're advocating violence when
you've never done any such thing it's
completely disingenuous
and it's completely disingenuous because
of the second point which is that
the libs would happily Advocate
political violence against their their
enemies
the libs the libs have made this point
all week with my transgenderism comments
they said you can't distinguish between
an idea and the people who Express that
idea there's no distinction to be made
if you criticize a bad idea then you are
calling for the death of the people who
hold that idea which is which is absurd
anybody with even a slightly developed
rational faculty is able to distinguish
between bad ideas and people who believe
bad ideas
but the libs don't fall into that group
the libs truly make no distinction
between those things and so when the
libs are calling for the eradication of
an idea
they actually are
in in certainly in the case of Jane
Fonda here calling for the eradication
of people it's sometimes said that every
accusation from the libs is a confession
and Jane Fonda just just confessed
something confessed that this whole past
week of the libs rewriting my words is
because they themselves
make no such distinction between ideas
and people
means that our society is getting pretty
crazy when things get crazy you're going
to want to make sure that your family is
protected you got to check out Jace
medical right now go to jacemedical.com
use promo code Knowles if the past
couple years has taught you anything it
should be that in a crisis say a global
pandemic or a natural disaster even the
basics can be hard to come by with
everything currently going on in the U.S
in the worst case scenario do you want
to be unprepared our partners over at
Jace medical are here to help Jace
medical helps you get a long-term supply
of prescription medication their mission
is to empower you to be better medically
prepared a great way to start preparing
us with the Jace case it's a pack of
five different courses of antibiotics
that you can use to treat a whole host
of bacterial illnesses including UTIs
respiratory infections sinusitis skin
infections and more all you've got to do
is fill out a simple online form and in
some cases jump on a quick call with one
of their board certified Physicians from
there you can ask your physician
treatment related question on an ongoing
basis I'll make it really simple for you
if China invades Taiwan as is looking
increasingly likely boom there goes your
supply chain make sure you're prepared
being prepared brings peace of mind that
the Knowles is that your family are
always going to be taken care of go to
jacemedical.com enter code Knowles at
checkout for a discount on your order
that is Jace with J medical.com promo
code Knowles
so what do the libs do now
now that the libs have flopped on their
on their desperate attempt not to allow
the transgender debate to be reframed
we went from do we trans the
five-year-olds or do we wait till they
turn eight to now the debate is do we
accept transgenderism at all or do we
not do we eradicate transgenderism
entirely from public life or do we
tolerate transgenderism throughout all
the public life that's where the debate
is it's not a good place for the libs to
have the debate so what do they do now
they Retreat to their tried and true
strategy of banning a word of redefining
a word BuzzFeed came out with this it's
now in Yahoo news
quote transgenderism is just the latest
example of anti-trans rhetoric
meaning
the word
transgenderism is now considered
Politically Incorrect
it's rare that we get to see this happen
in real time that the machinations of
political correctness
and having written an entire book about
the history and meaning of political
correctness called speechless
controlling words controlling mine's
number one National bestseller you can
order it there we go you can order it
whenever you like
you are now you're witnessing something
rare you were actually consciously
seeing the libs use political
correctness
by Banning a word
they tried to to redefine the meaning of
the word they tried to change the
language that we're all using that
didn't work this past weekend so they're
saying okay you're not allowed to say
anymore you're not if you saw the word
transgenderism trending on social media
last week and felt a sinking feeling in
your stomach you're not alone the word
was used at CPAC by daily wires Michael
Knowles who said during his speech the
transgenderism must be eradicated from
public life entirely
after his words were characterized as
sounding genocidal Knowles attempted to
claim that he was not calling for the
eradication of people when he said
transgender is a must be eradicated but
turning an experience intrinsic to the
lives of trans people into a noun
doesn't separate it from those people
whose rights and safety are currently
under attack first of all I didn't I
didn't turn it into a noun
transgenderism is a word that long
predates me
I just used the word correctly and the
libs were upset that I used the word
correctly and so now they're saying
you're not allowed to use it face I'm
kid you not they say
transgenderism is a phony term made up
by anti-transgender activists and used
to dehumanize transgender people and
Target them their life-saving health
care and access to society now what's
really weird is in the next paragraph
BuzzFeed says the term transgenderism
was actually used by trans activists in
the 1990s and early 2000s but as
language evolves words are both
reclaimed by communities and co-opted by
oppositional forces so so they say this
is a phony made up term from the
anti-trans activists actually no it's a
term that was used by the pro-trans
activists but now that Knowles is using
it it's terrible and we can't use it
anymore
funny made-up term it's just a word to
describe an idea and the libs can't
defend the idea they can't argue against
the people such as the conservatives who
are now pointing out the absurdity of
transgenderism
they can't do that and so what the only
thing they can do to try to win the
debate is to stop you from thinking
about it
which is the whole point of political
correctness
if you think about transgenderism for
five seconds you will realize that it is
completely absurd
you will realize that obviously men
cannot become women women cannot become
men men cannot secretly be women women
cannot secretly be men your true self
probably has something to do with your
body it's not totally divorced from your
body that you can look entirely like a
man and have every physical attribute of
a man but on some secret plane you're
actually a woman that's obviously absurd
and so the only way
that the Liberals can possibly defend
that idea and hold on to their political
position
is to stop you from thinking about it
and because words because language is
the stuff of our consciousness
it's not merely an instrument of our
Consciousness but it actually
constitutes our Consciousness it
constitutes the way that we view the
world if you can control the language
you can control people's minds you're
seeing that happen in real time right
now
why
because people know that
whatever I said in my CPAC speech
is just one of the million criticisms
that are resonating recently against
this tyranny of liberalism
it's just one example
but many other people have said many
similar things and it's resonating with
many many more people give me a great
example of this
the UK
according to the guardian
just ranked among the most liberal
countries
on divorce and abortion this according
to a global study
the UK ranks in the world's top four
countries for accepting divorce
homosexuality casual sex assisted dying
prostitution and abortion
and this is being hailed the supporters
are saying Bravo Live and Let Live the
battles against homophobia racism and
misogyny helped make the UK a more
liberal Nation but I don't think this
has to do with any kind of phobia or
misogyny or anything
just look at the facts here
the UK is now much more accepting of
divorce of the sexual revolution
of suicide of selling your body like
you're just a slab of meat of killing
your babies and that is not considered
to be the cost of liberalism
that's considered to be the feature
that's the the reward of liberalism the
great Triumph of liberalism is that
people are now having meaningless sex or
selling their bodies like they're
animals and are killing their babies and
or leaving their families that's we did
it guys we did it the divorce rate is
higher than ever we're murdering all our
babies congratulations if that's
liberalism
I don't want it
and I don't think I'm the weird one here
I think I'm I'm representing the normal
person's view which is if liberalism
means we destroy our families kill our
babies
tank our population engage in all sorts
of destructive behaviors then
something's wrong with liberalism I
think we need to be much less liberal I
think it would be great if our country
is if the motherland over in the UK If
the United States if the whole West
ranked much lower
on Global Studies of liberalism because
liberalism brings about pretty much
nothing but misery and National
destruction
if the Liberals know that the fruits of
liberalism have been poisonous and that
the people don't like it
and so the only way to salvage their
political program is to stop you from
talking about you're not really allowed
to say abortion you're supposed to say
reproductive Health Care women's rights
ridiculous euphemisms
you're not allowed to talk about divorce
you talk about our individual rights to
pursue our own desires the freedom to
destroy our families
you're not allowed to talk about suicide
you say no it's it's medical assistance
in dying it's how you transition no it's
just killing sad people and mentally ill
people and old people that's what it is
it's just
slaughtering her it's just killing
people
you kill the babies through abortion you
kill the old people through doctor
assisted suicide that's it that's the
and we don't want it
and we don't want that
and the libs don't want us thinking
about it because no reasonable person
wants any of that
that's the reality and so you've got to
push through this euphemistic language
to see the reality there was a tick tock
just went viral of a mother who had had
an abortion
getting through all of those euphemisms
all the rosy PR that the abortion
industry puts out there
showing people what abortion really
looks like for the mother
does nobody talk about how hard
abortions are on a woman
it's probably been a month
[Music]
and I hate myself every day
sucks because in the moment I felt like
I was doing the right thing
but every time
I'm going to better I'm just alone I
just think about like what if
because I'm not like I'm not a child
like I'm an adult so this just like hit
me on a different level I had all the
means in the world
to do it on my own
but I thought like I did it so that it
would benefit not just
me but also everyone else
I didn't even get the chance to like be
at home or anything like I just went to
work
I just want this to be over with already
like I'm emotionally drained I can't do
this anymore
your heart breaks for that woman because
even though she did a very evil thing
she doesn't seem to have quite
understood it she had bought into so
much of the pr of abortion so which is
which is everywhere
the pr which says oh this is no big deal
it's like getting your appendix removed
oh it's not nuts that you're in and out
it's just a clump of cells it's totally
it's not a baby it's meaningless just go
back to work the next day let's go
worker B
- we can't be having you taken any time
off to have a child or raise that child
no you got to make more widgets at the
factory that's your freedom that's the
fruit of feminism that's right you get
the privilege of killing your children
being pressured to do that by the
culture and then get right back to work
so you can earn a paycheck isn't that
aren't you so happy with your freedom
and she's now experienced this and she
says oh my god what have I done
I've done something evil
and I'm not even allowed to I've killed
my child and I'm not even allowed to
mourn it
I'm not even allowed to admit that I
killed my child
and I'm not allowed to mourn it because
if if I am granted even a few days of
mourning
then I would have to admit the reality
of what abortion is
and even if I personally am willing to
do that the society will not allow me to
do that
this poor mother your heart breaks for
this mother who's telling you the
reality of abortion she says I've just I
thought it was fine when I did it but
then I I went to bed and I can't get it
out of my head right the thing that's
nagging at you is your conscience
which your conscience can be dulled
through through the Indulgence of Vice
but it's still there you still have a
natural ability to discern between right
and wrong
still there and so you you still know
what's happening and the way abortion is
sold is okay here you go this is the
solution to your problem you got a
problem here's the solution almost as if
you're not going to have a life
afterward so you go you do it I'm not
denying that if you have an unplanned
pregnancy that raises all sorts of
anxiety that's what the abortion
industry preys on is women's Stress and
Anxiety and fear for the future in fact
that maybe the man won't stick around
but she says but I could have taken care
of the baby and I went and I and I
had a permanent solution to a temporary
problem and now I just think oh it's
over
an in place of relief I just feel this
sadness because now I'm never gonna
because I killed my kid
and nobody would even tell me what I was
doing
and now that I did it I nobody prepared
me for the sadness of the reality of
what I was doing that's what abortion
really looks like
beneath all the rosy euphemisms Women's
Health Care choice
freedom
that's the reality
speaking of women and conscience Grace
Van Dean who is one of the actresses in
stranger things
just came out and explained why she's
quitting Hollywood or at least taking a
break from Hollywood
and it's it's one of the most dignified
videos I've seen out of Hollywood in
years
turning down acting projects and
deciding to stream more but the fact of
the matter is the last few projects I've
worked on
I didn't have the best experiences one
of the last movies I did one of the
producers asked me to
like he hired a girl that was he was
sleeping with and then he had her ask me
to have a threesome with them
so like that's my boss
and so I don't really want to be
pressured to have threesomes with my
boss and so I'm having a new job now
which is similar to my old job but it's
a little bit different good honor
good honor
this is a reminder that integrity
has a cost to it
there are going to be all sorts of
Temptations in life to give up your
integrity to trade your integrity for a
little bit more fame or a little bit
more money or whatever
a little more convenience a little more
ease and she says no and so she's giving
up acting projects because she doesn't
want to take a ride on the casting couch
some people are saying well
she shouldn't have to pay the cost of
that Integrity this this Dirtbag
producer he should be held accountable
yeah he should
totally
he should with it we're so simple
that's not the way Hollywood works
don't look at us conservatives it's not
the conservatives who run Hollywood okay
that's that's not the way Hollywood
works that's not the way Hollywood has
ever worked
there's risk of corruption in all
Industries but especially show business
because the promise of Fame is so
tempting and so uh precious to so many
people and because the the commodity
that you are selling in Show Business is
yourself is your body
so it's no surprise that that commodity
is traded in the back rooms even as it's
traded on camera as well
and she knew that and so
Grace Van Deen could try to restart the
metoo movement the metoo movement was
always bogus it was always just a a PR
stunt
not not the women who were complaining
about the abuse but all of the Hollywood
Dirtbag men said oh ah he for she I'm
with her or I'm time's up me too they're
all the ones perpetrating it they had no
intention of changing their behavior it
was all totally fake
and so instead of Grace Van Dean saying
I'm gonna wait for reality to be
different than it has always been in
this dirty town
I'm just gonna I'm not gonna do it if
that's the cost of being a big star in
Hollywood I'm not going to do it I'll go
do something else
good honor
this is the consequence
of a theme that we've been talking about
for the past week which is feminism in
the sexual Revolution
feminism says women and men should be
treated exactly the same they're
indiscernible woman needs man like fish
needs a bicycle
well consequence of that is men are not
going to treat women with a special care
they're going to treat women the way
they treat men with the same kind of
roughness that they would treat men and
that's that's no good because men and
women really are different the sexual
Revolution is a consequence of feminism
says oh sex it's it can be totally
casual doesn't mean anything and so
sex is going to be traded as a casual
thing in Hollywood it's a direct
consequence of this and rather than try
to change the whole world Grace Grace
Van Deen says
I'm out see ya
good honor very very impressive
I think it's irrefutable though
all this sexual Revolution stuff
stemming from feminism has not succeeded
at what it promised to do which is make
everybody happier it has made everybody
more miserable I gave this talk in
Buffalo on Thursday
thousand people showed up even though
the room was relatively small it's only
about a 300 person room it's probably
500 protesters so even just the
protesters wouldn't have been able to
fit into the room and it was a fairly
modest speech on the history of feminism
and how it pertains to political
correctness wokeness leftism
relatively dry speech but people got so
wound up about it there was a debriefing
at the gender Institute of the
University of Buffalo
debriefing by these professors and
students to to
work through the Stress and Anxiety
caused by my campus lecture
this was a really emotional ex so I
think I'm going to go back a step and
say it was an awful experience
um and that probably the worst part of
it
was the absolute Glee that some of the
audience took honestly I have not seen
such Glee except maybe in you know Nazi
like propaganda you know like it was
really something the long lines were
engineered
um to create fear so there wasn't like
that's not
free in public discourse that's a
performance okay
so much there first of all the long
lines were engineered to create fear
the the long lines were a result of lots
of people showing up to the event
they weren't engineered there there was
a door to the event and people were
allowed in until it the room was filled
and when you are waiting to get into a
show or a lecture or any public space
you wait in a line it was the fear
the long lines of the fear and and but
if you did make it into the room the
worst part was the Glee people actually
liked what this awful man said and the
only time I've seen Glee like this was
in Nazi propaganda
if your only reference point
for Glee
is Nazi propaganda
something has gone seriously wrong in
your life if you if you can't when you
think of Glee you don't think of my
child's birthday party the the look on
my loved one's face as we watched the
sunset if you know you you're the only
gleeful experience that you can think of
is a Nazi propaganda movie
your life does not have enough Glee okay
you need to go outside and touch grass
and I don't know go watch a movie or
something you know take a walk on the
beach anything anything get get
something in your life that is not
totally misery inducing
but unfortunately
these people
live their lives in in accordance with
ideas that are not conducive to their
flourishing I mean that's the whole
point of the talk I said these ideas
such as feminism
promise to make you happy and then every
measure we have of it shows that they
have not made you happy they've made you
more and more miserable
so if you
if you suffer at any point in your life
well that's just life life has suffering
to it okay and you're gonna have bad
days and the rain falls on the just and
the unjust alike and that's just part of
it
but if you are
constantly miserable
if you never ever feel Glee and someone
else exhibiting happiness causes you
pain
that's on you something something is
wrong in your mind
and you need to change your mind a
little bit or else you're going to
continue living a very miserable life
you've seen this throughout higher
education not just at the University of
Buffalo
Stanford Law School
Stanford law school just
exhibited one of the most shameful
displays I have ever seen or heard of
in a university
a judge showed up to give a talk at
Stanford law school Stanford law school
is ranked the number two law school in
America judges fifth Circuit Judge Kyle
Duncan
he showed up to a federalist Society
event
and then students showed up to protest
it
screaming obscene disgusting sexual
vulgar things at him calling him a liar
calling him a scumbag
at a certain point judge Duncan had had
enough of this he said Can someone I
don't know what these people are doing
but could someone please get an
administrator in here to bring order
back to a classroom at Stanford Law
School
so the administrator shows up
the administrator takes the side of the
shrieking howling vulgar obscene crazy
students
the administrator shows up to do we have
a video clip of this
and I'm just asking for an administrator
[Music]
ideas
like do you want an echo chamber what's
the issue
[Music]
[Applause]
can I have to write something down
because I'm so uncomfortable up here
um and I don't say that for sympathy I
just say I'm deeply deeply uncomfortable
um I'm uncomfortable because this event
is tearing at the fabric of this
community that I care about and I'm here
to support
and I don't know and I
and I just worth the squeeze and it's
uncomfortable to say this to you as a
person it's uncomfortable to say that
for many people here your work has
caused harm
is the juice worth the squeeze that's
the administrator
is that she says look it's your lecture
is tearing us all apart at this
community and I guess you have a right
to give it and so this is very very
terrible and the judge shows up and
gives a talk
and the administrator is called in to
put down these howling banshees and say
pipe down so you can listen to your your
better pipe down so you can listen to an
actual federal judge from whom you can
learn quite a lot if any of you ever
want to be lawyers or judges someday
and she says you know is the juice worth
the squeeze
R.I.P higher education
very the scary part is not that this is
the number two Law School in the country
by the way the number one law school
Yale law school had a very similar
incident last year with Christian
Wagoner from the alliance defending
Freedom Kristen Wagner very respected
judge Supreme Court litigator shows up
gives a talk on religious liberty and
the students also start screaming and
howling like a bunch of animals
and the the Stanford Administration the
Yale Administration they both pay the
lip service afterwards okay this wasn't
totally great uh-uh unless that
administrator at Stanford is fired
unless those students are expelled then
it's all just BS talk is cheap okay the
fear is not even just that higher
education is dead that the most
prestigious law schools in the countries
are dead
the fear is that these people are going
to be lawyers someday
these people might be judges someday
the fear is not just that higher
education is is gone it's that our whole
system of Law and Order and civil
government is gone
what if I told you that there's one book
that is done more for literacy than any
other book it is shaped literature art
culture government and countless lives I
am of course referring to the Bible you
know who else the Bible's had an
influence on Jordan B Peterson in
addition to his Exodus series Jordan has
a documentary called logos and literacy
where he traces the Bible through
history to show you the impact that it
has had on the Western World here's the
trailer
I was very much struck by how the
translation of the biblical writings
jump started the development of literacy
across the entire world illiteracy was
the norm the pastor's home was the first
school and every morning it would begin
with singing the Christian faith is a
singing religion probably 80 percent of
scripts memorization today exists only
because of what is sung this is amazing
here we have a Gutenberg Bible printed
on the price of Johann goonberg science
and religion are opposing forces in the
world but historically that has not been
the case now the book is available to
everyone from Shakespeare to modern
education and medicine and science to to
civilization itself it is the most
influential book in all history and
hopefully people can walk away with at
least a sense of that
this is the part where I would normally
tell you that logos and literacy is only
available for daily wire Plus members
but we are making it available for free
for everybody at dailywireplus.com only
for a limited time though so watch logos
I'm going to receive today at
dailywireplus.com
speaking of hysterical leftists
a few months early here but I'm
I'm prepared to bring this out now
got to give a hat tip to jack besobic
for calling my attention to this
June 21st 2018.
Greta tunberg Saint Greta of the Blessed
sailboat tweets out
a top climate scientist is warning that
climate change will wipe out all of
humanity unless we stop using fossil
fuels over the next five years
Greta has apparently deleted this tweet
I'm just going to look at my
calculations here as in 2018 now it's
2023 carry the seven oh
it's been five years
Alma it's been four years and what nine
months
we are approaching the end of the world
aren't we and yet
the behavior of people might seem to
predict the end of the world but the
natural facts of the earth seem just
fine
another Doomsday Prophecy
has not come true
as all the rest of the Doomsday
prophecies have not come true this is
what the libs always do
they tell you that in 12 years 10 years
five years the world is going to end
unless you do exactly what they demand
that you do unless you give them all the
money and all the power and then then
maybe we'll avert the end of the world
and then those prophecies never come
true but they're so far into the future
that the libs assume that you'll never
call them out when they don't come true
this has been the case since
well since all of human history but it
goes back to the the population bomb
Paul Ehrlich and the population bomb
said in 1970 that within 10 years there
would be Mass famines the world
population would plummet it was
inevitable we could start now
sterilizing people and and killing
babies through abortion and we might
need to even coerce it but it's still
not going to help all that much these
these predictions led directly to
policies in places like India which
sterilized lots of poor people in
exchange for the use of utilities places
like China which had the one one child
policy killed Untold numbers of babies
because of these sorts of predictions
and then
didn't come true
didn't matter actually
50 years on the world population doubled
malnutrition was in an all-time low
oops got it wrong it's always wrong it's
all these predictions
that climate change about the population
bomb about from the end of the world
they're always false and it's important
to celebrate when they don't come true
shouldn't we be happy shouldn't great to
be happy why doesn't Greta retweet this
and say hello how wonder I don't really
know how the swedes sound don't you know
this is so wonderful the world hasn't
ended yippee hooray no they're upset
when it doesn't happen they hide it they
have to delete it remember oh my
calculations were a little wrong uh but
uh three more years if you don't give me
what I want in three more years that's
when the world is going to end okay see
you in three more years
what's the point of all this the Energy
Secretary for Joe Biden explained what
the point of all of this is I think
China has done
um has been very sensitive and has
actually invested a lot in their
Solutions uh to achieve their goals so
we're we're hopeful that you know we can
all learn from what China is doing but
the amount of money that they're
investing in clean energy is actually
you know encouraging
there it is there's the point
the point is to make our system of
government look more like China's
it's not just Jennifer granholm and the
Biden Administration is saying this the
world economic Forum has been saying
this liberal Elites all over the world
have been saying this they look at
China's model and they say oh that's a
pretty good way for the elite to take a
lot of power over the people
what's the model the model is mass
surveillance the model is a social
credit system and the model is the total
control of people's habits of living all
the way down to what kind of stoves they
use to heat their pots of gruel all the
way down to what kind of Transportation
they're allowed to take whether or not
they're able to leave their homes
all the way down and how do they justify
it
they justified in the name of this
eschatology of climate change this woke
pseudo-religion that has all of the
elements of a religion all of the kind
of
Quasi sacraments
all of the kinds of rituals all the
kinds of liturgical garments and of
course
the end times prophecies
that climate change exists to animate
this move away from our traditional way
of life toward this new way of life and
it's not just that this new way of life
is communist it's not just that China is
a purely communist country it's not
China uses Market mechanisms
China I don't think Xi Jinping is the
most ideologically Orthodox Marxist
that's ever lived
and frankly I don't think that their
system is all that different from the
system in the west we have the same kind
of mass surveillance that China does in
fact we have a much more sophisticated
system of mass surveillance that we use
against our own people
we have a social credit system whether
the United States wants to admit it or
not
if you if you contradict the ruling
regime you can have your
Uber shutdown you can be put on a no-fly
list you can be debanked this has
happened to political dissidents in the
United States
and because our society is increasingly
moving away from cash you can be you can
be frozen out of the the system out of
the financial system
you won't be able to protest either
because you'll be de-platformed from
social media which is the Public Square
doesn't look all that different so when
when the ruling class liberals tell you
we want to look like China believe them
they're telling you their plans
and and you're you're even seeing this
impulse in the way they use language
the idea that in the total state in a
totalitarian regime
everything down to your private thoughts
is controlled by the ruling power
the words that you are allowed to use
history
what actually happened what people
actually said no no you didn't hear that
no no no you didn't see that no no no
history is always changing
reality is always changing the party
whatever the party says is always right
it's music Monday baby
the rest of the show continues now you
don't want to miss it become a member
right now if you're not already a member
the aliwire.com Knowles use code Knowles
at checkout for two months free on all
annual plans
[Music]